[Music]
in the ballet world there are two types
of dancers you have a male dancer and a
female dancer there's really no
in-between growing up I really didn't
fit that binary
but I really do know who I am today I'm
a transgender ballerina
[Music]
this great big story was made possible
by Procter and Gamble I was born a male
but I have always known that I've been
gender fluid in my head and in my heart
I really did feel that I was female it's
something everyone that I've met has
known oh look
nine-year-old J oh I have been dancing
as a male since I was five but I was
never able to really express myself
fully as a male dancer you have to be
able to do a lot of partnering it was
really hard for me to pick up and I just
felt more than a girl was partnering a
girl there really was no right place for
me to fit in
[Music]
when I was alone I danced how I wanted
to dance I was just able to be free for
a few hours and be able to just express
myself I wanted to express myself when I
was 17 I was in a pre-professional
program at a school and when I decided
to come out to the school the school was
not as accepting as my parents and I
thought it was going to be at the end of
the school year they told me that they
did not want me to come back as a female
and they were not going to extend my
scholarship as a female I sort of gave
up trying to prove myself to the school
because I really would rather be
somewhere where I feel wanted
[Music]
after the school year ended I went back
home to train with my parent dance
studio for state dance academy as my
true self as a female and dancing there
makes me feel very supported and I'm in
a class where I can just dance and not
have to worry about the outside world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there aren't really many differences
when it comes to male and female
training we go through bar center jumps
turns it's just as a male dancer you
tend to jump a little bit more whereas
females do pointe work I think the most
difficult part of dancing on point is
everything you're basically standing on
top of your toes in these hard shoes but
weight on your back foot
Segan move your foot I really was
surprised to see that point wasn't as
easy and graceful as the other girls
made it but the more that I did it
throughout the week and classes and
rehearsals the more that my feet started
to mold to my shoes there you go
good job after a month of trading on
pointe my dance teacher cast me as a
snow queen in her production of the
Nutcracker it was nerve-racking because
it was my first role as a female I was
shocked at the fact that I didn't mess
up at all but
I was more excited to just perform in
front of an audience at the end of the
day I really am just a ballerina my goal
is to dance professionally I'm just like
the other girls I am working hard and
I'm striving to get to where I want to
be
[Music]